The 2008 horror film "The Strangers"
has become a disturbing classic,
and an excellent example of the
home invasion genre of horror.
Lock the door and join us as we explore the
meaning of the film's dark, nihilistic ending.
Kristen and James ride in uncomfortable
silence. It's a cool night in February,
and the pair are making their way from
a friend's wedding reception to James'
summer home. James was so sure that Kristen
was going to accept his marriage proposal.
Kristen's tear-stained face says
it all: Where do they go from here?
There's a knock on the door. A
blonde woman, bathed in shadow,
asks for Tamara. After an awkward
exchange, they send her on her way.
James attempts to gather his thoughts
and leaves on a night drive, leaving
Kristen alone in the house. Then, suddenly,
another knock. More insistent this time.
[Knocking on the door]
[Loud bang]
Kristen grabs a knife and starts
charging her phone. The landline is dead
and she can't shake the feeling
that someone is in the house.
So begins "The Strangers," which
barrels forward with unrelenting energy,
pitting the emotionally strained couple against
three masked assailants. James returns to find
Kristen a mess, and he soon finds out
why. Together they attempt to survive
in their own home, defend themselves,
and call for help, all to no avail.
At the end of their terrifying night, James
is missing and Kristen is badly injured.
Her attempts to signal for help from a remote
radio are a bust, and upon returning to the
house the power cuts out. Limping and
surrounded by the masked intruders,
Kristen attempts to find James, only to be knocked
out by the towering male in the group. She awakens
tied to a chair next to James, distraught
and defeated with one searing question: why?
Kristen wakes up to the sound of
Pin-Up Girl opening the drapes.
Warm sunlight floods the room. Kristen
grunts against her tight restraints, kicking
and whimpering as her three masked assailants
stand silently over her and the defeated James.
We tend to expect horrific things to take place
under the cover of darkness; things that slink,
creep, and strike while we're
sleepy, vulnerable, and alone.
Evolutionary psychologists have theorized that our
fear of the dark lingers from the days when human
beings weren't at the top of the food chain,
when nocturnal predators were a real threat.
Horror films take advantage of
our instinctual fear of the dark,
allowing our imaginations to run wild
and conjure up worst-case scenarios.
In genre cinema, horrific things tend to lurk
in the shadows. That said, there's no shortage
of horror film baddies that work in the light.
The man-eating shark in "Jaws" didn't confine
its reign of terror to the shadows and neither
do the trio of killers in "The Strangers." And
this is precisely what makes the climax
of their murderous assault so disturbing.
They open the curtains before
killing Kristen and James, unafraid
and unconcerned with the possibility
that some prying neighbor might
see. The fact that "The Strangers" ends bathed
in sunlight is both unexpected and terrifying;
further cementing the film's core theme
that random acts of violence are exactly
that: random. This isn't the kind of evil
that is miraculously banished by the sun.
There are few glimmers of hope throughout
"The Strangers." One of them is when Mike
(played by Dennis Reynolds
himself, Glenn Howerton)
arrives at the house in response to James' upset
voice message. Mike's a good pal. His friend's
marriage proposal fell through and here he is
at god knows what hour to pick up the pieces.
Unfortunately, Mike's good intentions lead
to his demise. Waltzing into the house,
oblivious of the situation, he's shot in
the face by James' itchy trigger finger.
To be fair, when a person blows their best
friend's face off, the first reaction isn't
typically to steal his cell phone. Even
as an audience member, it's easy to forget
that Mike has a phone that could be Kristen
and James' chance to contact the police.
After the incident, James announces that
he's going to try and call for help — not
by checking his dead friend's pockets — but by
venturing out for the two-way radio in the woods.
To be fair, the movie wants us to forget that Mike
has a cell phone, so that it can make a dramatic
appearance in the final act. Bleeding out on
the floor, Kristen hears Mike's phone ring,
something we didn't even realize was there.
Upon coming-to, lashed to a chair,
Kristen breathlessly asks the trio
what we've all been wondering:
"Why are you doing this to us?"
"Because you were home."]
This attack has nothing to do with
Kristen and James' relationship struggles,
with the apparent wealth of James' family,
or with any sinister occult purpose. They answered
the door. It's just that random and simple.
Indeed, the scariest thing about "The
Strangers" isn't the masks, the jump scares,
or the bloodshed. Instead, the film offers a
glimpse into the terrifying notion that sometimes
bad things happen ... just because. There's
no grand reveal and no explanation for our
villains' actions. When the assailants
remove their masks, Kristen and James
don't recognize their faces. The killers are,
as the film title suggests, just strangers.
This hits especially hard in these final moments
— even at the film's end, there are no answers.
All we're left with is pure dread. Because we
know so little about these anonymous boogeymen,
they are able to remain just that: Something
that can go bump in the night without
any warning or purpose. The conclusion
isn't here to satisfy your curiosity.
Satisfied with the damage they've inflicted,
our now unmasked trio exit James' summer
house and pile into their pickup. Their truck
passes two Mormon boys, walking their bikes
on the side of the road. They stop and chat
with the boys, then continue down the road.
As they drive away, Pin-Up Girl makes a
curious comment to Dollface. She says:
"It'll be easier next time."
The internet loves theorizing, and passionate
Redditors believe Pin-Up's comment may imply
that the events we see in the film were
an initiation rite of sorts for Dollface.
Indeed, if you look at the trio's masks and their
credited names, a sort of hierarchy emerges.
Man in Mask never speaks; he’s a dominating
presence who towers over his two smaller peers.
Pin-Up Girl always appears
assured and well-practiced,
with a name suggesting a degree of maturity.
Dollface, meanwhile, is another story;
a weak voice beneath a wide-eyed childish
mask. It's possible that she's new to this.
This interpretation potentially
puts Pin-Up Girl's comment,
that it will be easier next time, into context.
Dollface's struggle with the acts she’s committed
is further implied by her interactions
with the Mormon boys. She's a sinner,
and she's a little shaken up by what she's just
done. But next time, it won't be her first rodeo.
The idea for "The Strangers" came
from a number of different real-life
sources. While you have to go digging through
the film's bonus features and production notes
to uncover how writer-director Bryan Bertino's
own brush with home invasion inspired the film,
the ending of "The Strangers" hammers home
some of the film's more well-known sources.
As our unmasked trio pile into their pickup
truck, the connective tissue to the famous
Tate–LaBianca murders is unavoidable. As Bertino
recounted in an interview, the film was indeed
in direct conversation with the murders enacted
by the Manson Family. Bertino explained that
learning about the story of Charles Manson and his
followers, along with the group's seeming lack of
any singular motivation, had a massive impact on
him and his understanding of the minds of killers.
Writer Britt Hayes notes another source of
inspiration for the film. This incident is
known as the Keddie Cabin Murders, an
unsolved quadruple homicide that took
place in a California railroad town in 1981.
One of the most unnerving similarities between
"The Strangers" and the Keddie Cabin Murders
takes place during the film's conclusion.
With Kristen and James bound to chairs in their
living room and stabbed in the early morning,
the scene bears a strong resemblance to
the fates of some of the case's victims.
Love 'em or hate 'em, jump scares are an essential
part of horror films. While not all screamers,
as they’re sometimes called, are created
equal, some are nobler than others.
The word "stingers" describes the
jump scare that gives the audience
one last jolt before the credits
roll — and believe it or not,
it's a time-honored tradition. There's the dream
sequence at the end of "Carrie," for instance,
where our witchy heroine's bloodied arm bursts
out of her rocky grave to snatch the traumatized
Sue. And who could forget the final shot of
the franchise-originator "Friday the 13th,"
when Jason's decomposing corpse springs
out of Crystal Lake for one final shock?
A final jump scare is a totally acceptable
(if a bit silly) way to end a horror film.
"The Strangers" keeps that tradition alive.
As the two Mormon boys (who are going to need
some serious therapy after this) venture into the
house, they spy James and Kristen's mangled bodies
and investigate. Hovering over Kristen, the
boys take in the crime scene with a frankly
eerie silence, dumbstruck perhaps at
the gruesome bloodbath before them.
One boy hovers over Kristen's body,
extending his hand towards her face.
Then: bam. Kristen comes
to, screaming. Cut to black.
Considering the film's nihilistic attitude,
Kristen's survival is initially surprising.
But upon closer inspection, the assailants leaving
her alive gives us some disturbing insight into
the killers' psyche. They are not concerned with
the act of killing, or even being caught. All that
interests them is the violence — rhyme,
reason, or consequence be damned.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.